you have a huge research team that's
been collecting I think I heard 500
billion pieces of data in one form or
another given the fact that these
outcomes that you're talking about are
so unbelievable are you having to work
additionally hard be additionally
rigorous when it comes to the science in
order to dispel any accusations of the
pseudo science stuff um gosh what a
great conversation thanks for asking the
question um the whole
reason that I started measuring and
we've been measuring for a long time now
um was because when I saw someone with
Ms in a wheelchair come to the event in
a wheelchair and walk out without one I
said we got to start measuring I mean
what is happening in that person's brain
what is happening in their body what's
happening in their biology what's
happening on a cellular level what's is
their information in their blood what's
happening to their immune system and we
we started you know Gathering you know
um a lot of data I mean we have way over
500 billion data points that's usually
just one or two
studies and and so when we started
partnering with the University of
California San Diego I simply said to
those scientists okay same thoughts same
choices same behaviors same experiences
same emotions that's the
known same
biology sounds right new thoughts new
choices new Behaviors new experiences
new emotions new
biology possibly that's a good
hypothesis you want to measure
it so we've measured so many things in
the human body that says that you can
change your brain to work way better in
four days you can make your heart way
better you can express new genes uh you
could release thousands of metabolites
thousands and thousands of metabolites
in 7 days that promote growth and repair
in your body um we find information in
meditators blood that has a resistance
to viruses all kinds of viruses even
ones with spikes um that the information
Advanced meditators blood somehow
diminishes mitochondrial function in
cancer cells that's the that's the
energy in the cell not a little bit but
70% which is dramatic and cancer cells
love to multiply and move and they have
no energy um they don't live as long uh
there's information in the blood of
advanced meditators uh that somehow
downregulates the gene for Alzheimer's
uh we're finding uh robust amounts of
endogenous opiates that reduce pain
across the board we measured
6 three different Health uh conditions
63 different diseases um all different
diseases one intervention and uh uh the
majority of those people have a
significant reduction in pain and a very
elevated level of endogenous opiates in
their in their bloodstream you know
natural pain relievers natural chemicals
that make you feel good um uh and and um
so we just we've explored the microbiome
we've see that you can change your
microbiome in seven days to look like a
way healthier person without taking a
probiotic without changing your diet
without eliminating anything
somehow um the microbiome changes
dramatically for the better
and the reason is because they're not
the same person any longer they're a
different person um so we've spent the
last four years working with the
University of California San Diego in
doing extensive research on the brain
extensive research uh on heart uh heart
measurements um a lot of blood values
urine uh um everything we've measure we
we measure saliva we measure breast milk
we measure tears I mean we've measured
uh just about everything yeah and are
these published these results are
published yes we have some papers that
are published now um we have some papers
that are in peer review right now we
have about five more papers uh that we
uh getting busy writing but we have we
probably have the largest database uh in
the world on on meditation right
now what are the most common criticisms
that you get wow
um I would say that you know when you
see the empirical
science uh a lot of people um
that see the data uh whether we show it
to reputable universities and and
professors or to NASA or to whoever I
think one of the things that people have
the
most there's the most shock and surprise
is that you never see these type of
changes in seven days like you drug
study you don't ever see these kind of
we're talking about uh thousands of
genes up regulated to suggest the
person's living in a completely
different environment uh completely
completely different life and they're in
a ballroom you know so so when you see
the effects change like that in seven
days anybody who's a scientist that has
that uh trained mind they're going to
fall out of their chair because it's the
the the metagenomics arounded is not
just one or two people it's the it's the
whole entire group so think about it
1500 2,000 2500 different people all
different genotypes everybody has their
own Gene sequence okay at the end of
seven days 77% of those people are
signaling the same genes and making the
same
proteins that's kind of wild that means
that the flock the herd the school you
know there everybody's evolving there's
an emergent Consciousness that's
actually everybody's biology is evolving
together like and that's and that's
exciting because people change people
that's what we discovered so when we
show the data to people um and you they
see it uh the conversation that we used
to have where we'd have to be on the
defense has changed dramatically because
these are double blind and triple blind
Placebo studies these are there're very
very rigorous studies so so the
scientist that sees it questions the
time and then you know a drug study is
about 25% effective you know and it
usually takes um 3 to 6 months before
you see the efficacy turn out our data
is like somewhere uh uh between 75 and
100% so it's it it shows that that the
nervous system is the greatest
pharmacist in the world that actually
works better than any drug so so when
when people really begin to see the
science and and and you know they it
challenges their belief it challenges I
keep telling the scientists I can't
believe this is the truth like I'm more
surprised than anybody but I also say to
them where do those chemicals come from
where are they coming from the person's
not taking opiates they're not taking
anti-carcinogen they're they're not
taking anything uh to change their
biology like this is coming from within
them um so it's been changing the
conversation uh in medicine uh quite a
bit and we're just working on finding
the language but but but people who see
the data um are very surprised and they
want to know what we're doing which
which is which is a different
conversation that we've had uh in the
past are you doing longitudinal studies
are you seeing how long the immersive
stuff what what sort of effects does
this lock in over time are people
reverting as soon as they're out of this
very energetic group of people what's
happening time yeah that's a great
question um so um that's one of the
things about uh this work that I really
really love in terms of our community um
it's not like people go oh V I got to go
meditate today it's the morning it's
that's not how our community is like the
majority of the people that come to a
week-long event keep doing the work and
the majority of them do because the
Magic in their life is starting to
happen and why would you want to stop um
from from having those events uh you
know actually take place so we see that
people who heal this sounds kind of
crazy and we've
there's we've had a lot of people
instantaneously have a
reversal in a health condition from one
meditation from one inward experience
there's an arousal that takes place in
their nervous system they move into
these heightened states of gamma brain
wave patterns uh uh the person is having
an inward experience that's greater than
the Betrayal or the trauma from the past
and somehow there's a there's an upgrade
in their biology like there's the eczema
now it's gone um there's the mosia
gravis now it's gone there's a
Parkinson's was there now it's gone
there's the cancer now it's gone there's
the deafness now the person's hearing
now the blindness is the person's seeing
it's like that it's like the person
comes back and there's an upgrade right
what do you think's happening inside of
the body what's going on okay so anyway
let me let me finish that that thought
and then I'll answer because because
it's important to ask that question
those people who have those biological
upgrades that are instantaneous um when
we measure them three three months down
the road six months down the road nine
months down the road there's a there's a
sustained change they got the upgrade if
they continue to do the practice no no
no even if they don't do the practice
they got they got a very good upgrade
now a certain percentage of people that
that have an upgrade like that and they
go back to the stressful life the
Parkinson's Returns the cancer returns
because they're back to the same
personality again and they're making
their same chemistry now many of those
people continue in that direction other
people catch themselves and they said if
I change this Parkinson's once because
my father's in the hospital and I'm
emotionally reative Ed I can change it
again and they actually change it again
right so um so um and then there's
people who go through that process of
breaking the habit of being themselves
and and becoming Reinventing another
person and it's a it's a constant
process of change you kind of got a
super responder with the first one and
done type person yeah one one connection
um one moment uh of connection uh like
like a brainstorm uh and those people
who cross a river of change they tend to
do the work consistently because they
want to keep changing they're not doing
their meditations to heal they're doing
their meditations to change and when
they understand when they change they
heal so it's the process of change that
they're interested in so so we have a
good percentage of people who do the
work and after they finish the immersive
experience that sustain those changes
and we have a lot of people that suain
changes whether they do it or or they
don't do it so what's happening in their
biology that's a great
question um let me see if I can answer
this um in a methodical
way um your senses plug you into
three-dimensional reality right so if I
took away your sight if I took away your
hearing I took away your smell your
taste and feeling with your body you
would have no experience of
three-dimensional reality but you would
still be conscious but you would be
conscious of nothing material or
physical you would just be conscious
that you're conscious and you would be
conscious of nothing in a sense
so when a person is immersed in
three-dimensional reality um their
neocortex their thinking brain is super
busy scanning the environment and
associating gnes and and uh it's got to
process a lot of information that's
coming in through the senses what it's
seeing what it's hearing what it's
smelling what it's tasting what it's
feeling and that a lot a lot of that
information is coming in and the brain's
job is to create meaning between your
inner world and your outer world and if
you were to measure a person's brain
waves they're pretty much in beta brain
wave patterns and that means you're
conscious you're awake and you're aware
that you're in a body local in space and
Tom you're aware of your environment and
you're aware of time and that's how we
navigate in three-dimensional reality
and there's neurotransmitters in the
brain that support that
okay if I said to you um you got to do a
speech and it's got to be done uh by by
without any notes you got about 45
minutes prepare um your brain would kind
of perk up a little bit and you it would
be kind of a good stress you'd have to
perform you're confident you'd have to
get ready you'd have to change your
state you'd have to think you'd have to
all right what do I want to talk about I
got I got to change my state you would
move into mid-range beta light bulb gets
a little brighter and you're a little
bit more ready uh in a sense but when
you react in you're emotional and you're
stressed and you're out of balance you
go into this very high beta brain wave
pattern
and that's three times as high as
low-level beta that's when the brain is
in first gear on the freeway it is it is
you consuming all of its energy and it's
sweeping the environment and it's
shifting its attention from one person
to another person to another problem to
another thing to another place it's
trying to forecast it's trying to
predict and the Brain starts firing very
very disintegrated it starts it's firing
incoherently out of order and people
they need a drug or they need a drink or
they need something to take away that
kind of state and and their their
thoughts are literally driving the brain
into higher and higher states of of beta
they're they're their addiction to those
thoughts are driving the brain out of
balance okay so when you're in that
state you're very narrow focused you're
you're obsessing on things that's what
what the brain does it overthinks it
over it over analyzes now so if you can
change your brain waves from beta to
Alpha now your inner world starts
becoming more real than your outer World
in in a sense you're you become more
creative your brain stops talking to you
in your head you stop analyzing you
start seeing in images you start seeing
in pictures and Alpha is an imaginary
very creative state you're still aware
of your outer environment but not so
much okay so here's the answer to your
question if you can get so
relaxed that your body moves into a
light
State and it's in a light rest and
you're conscious and awake now you're in
Theta and that's a very hypnotic state
and when you're in a hypnotic State
you're in a state of trans and you're
very suggestible to information and
suggestibility is your ability to accept
information to believe the information
to surrender to it and and that's what
can program a person's do about just
about anything right so hypnotist uses
when he's when he's making suggestions
the person who's in Theta the door
between their conscious mind and the
subconscious mind is wide open to
information okay so that makes sense uh
if you're getting information through
your senses and you're in Theta you're
in a hypnotic state but what if the
person's eyes are
closed what
if there's music filling the space
they're not eating they're not tasting
they're not smelling they're not
experiencing they're not feeling and
they're in that realm of theta and I ask
them instead of the put their all of
their attention on everything physical
and everything material to open their
awareness instead of narrow their focus
broaden their focus and put their
attention on not on the material but on
the immaterial not on the particle but
the wave not on matter but on energy and
and and the atom is
99.9999% information and energy okay so
having the person focus on nothing this
is the funny part about it and
broadening their focus if they can dial
down their thinking neocortex the Theta
they'll have no experience of their body
no experience of their environment and
no experience of time and they're in
Theta they're still suggestible to
information but they're not aware of
their outer environment but they're
still suggestible there's only one other
place that information comes from and
that's frequency and all frequency radio
waves Wi-Fi waves uh x-rays all carry
information so when the person opens
their awareness to the wave function to
energy and to information they pay more
attention to that and less attention to
thems more they connect more to that and
less to the three-dimensional reality if
there's if there's coherence in the
brain all of a sudden the person has a
moment of
connection and the Brain goes into a
gamma brain wave state and Gamma now is
an arousal it's superc
Consciousness but it's not coming from
Fear it's not coming from aggression or
anger it's not coming from Pain the
arousal is ecstasy a person is making
connection and and when we measure the
amount of gamma that's taking place in
the person's
brain 3% uh 2% to 3% of the population
in anything that we're measuring really
good is three standard deviations
outside of normal uh these people are
200 300 400 500 standard deviations
outside of normal and three is really
great is this on an fmri this is a
quantitative EG and we see the same
pattern the limic brain the seat of the
autonomic nervous system is functioning
in a very very
coherent highly organized very very fast
frequency of gamma now remember stress
is autonomic
disregulation right disregulation in the
autonomic nervous system moving out of
balance these high states of gamma is
autonomic regulation now the autonomic
nervous system controls and coordinates
every system in the body and if it's if
it's processing an energy in a frequency
that fast every single cell in the body
is getting the information and the
body's literally raised in energy and
raised in frequency and that that's when
you see the instantaneous upgrade that
goes on biologically in a person's body
and we actually now can predict it when
we see a person move to a certain level
of theta we can say oh boy this is going
to be really good like really good and
that person um is having a very very
powerful internal experience what is the
felt sense that somebody will tend to go
through during that process what's the
what's the embodied subjective
experience of going through this so we
have a we have a a scientist that um
studies the language of
transformation from the University of
Central Oklahoma a super great guy and
he's been studying the language of
transformation and all the testimonials
of all the many of the people who have
had these
moments and
um the subjective experience is
twofold um it's very um
somatic when I mean somatic I mean like
they say uh like every single cell in my
body uh was vibrating at a faster
frequency I felt the incredible my heart
felt like it was going to blow open um I
felt like I was filled with light
they'll give you like something very
somatic like oh my God it was I felt
this in my body and then it's also very
emotional that's the other part but it's
not like emotional like I've never felt
love I thought I understood love I
thought I have felt love I've never felt
love like this I felt so connected I
felt so whole I felt so pure um I I felt
it was the most familiar unfamiliar
feeling I've ever had oh my God I forgot
uh I forgot that I was that it was
within me whatever um and then and then
the other element is after that they
they have a language where they only can
use metaphor to describe the unknown
experience they'll say um yeah my heart
turned on like an engine
the top of my head blew off there was
lightning coming out of my fingertips
they're they they're trying to explain
but they'll say well it wasn't
lightening really it just felt like this
but it was more like this so um so the
the language uh specialist that has been
studying this had his own moment uh at
uh an event we did in Marco Island uh
last September where he connected and um
I sat down with him and talked to him
and he could not find the language the
language guy the language guy could not
find the language to explain what the
heck happened to him but he was totally
switched on so so there's there's an
arousal that takes place uh there's High
gamma brain wave patterns it's autonomic
regulation it's very sematic it's very
emotional and and um there people
describe it kind of like a connection in
other news this episode is brought to
you by momentus a lot of supplements say
that they're top quality but very few
can actually prove it and momentus has
the most most rigorous third party
testing of any supplement company that
I've ever found Andrew hubman is the
scientific adviser for them my favorite
product from them is their sleep pack
which contains everything that you need
for a good night's sleep including
magnesium L3 38 appenine and eleanine in
the optimal doses to help you get a
better deeper more restful night's sleep
this is all that you need you can throw
it in your bag you can take it with you
on the road or you can just take it
every single evening it's made a massive
difference to the quality of my sleep
best of all they've got a 30-day money
back guarantee so you can buy anything
and try it for 29 days and if you don't
like it they will give you your money
back they ship internationally and you
can get free us shipping on orders over
$75 right now you can get a 20% discount
on everything sitewide by going to the
link in the description below or heading
to live mos.com modern wisdom using the
code modern wisdom a checkout that's Liv
mous.com wisdom and modern wisdom a
checkout thank you very much for tuning
in if you enjoyed that clip with Joe you
will love the full length 3our long
podcast in all its Glory right here go
on give it a tap